so welcome everybody hope you are having
a great
day i have a load of exams and papers
that are due
so i also have a bunch of allergies that
are
coming up and down so this should be fun
but um
so this is this right now this three
hours is such a
such a bless and such a time off for me
this is amazing
i really needed this so i am very very
happy to be here
i'm usually happy to be here but today
i'm extra happy because
just i cannot look at biochemistry and
pharmacology anymore oh
just yeah and i can't really leave my
room because when i leave my room
i sneeze and i get all puffed up
allergies that i
i'm still not sure what i'm allergic to
so
yeah i am boarding a house i'm in a
house board
and looking at my 150 page study guide
and enjoy my time here with you
so i would like to um
kind of know how you guys are doing that
would be great
because um i really do like this class
because
we are very interactive i get a lot of
awesome chat and awesome ideas
and that's one thing that i absolutely
love about
this class so let me make sure
my tea is not going to follow my laptop
that would be a disaster
i think i had a dream like that but i
burned something down
by putting water on it i've been having
some weird drinks
all right so the first game that we are
going to take a look at
is oscar capoblanca 1914
this game kind of jumps in the end game
too fast
so if we are lucky we would be able to
get another game
squeeze another game in two pc is
walking right here
because i've been having few um not
exactly happiest days of my life
uh phd has been super affectionate every
time i'm sleeping i wake up he's like i
write under my chest or being a little
spoon and it is just
too cute pinching is the best
all right so um let's go ahead and take
a quick look
we'll parallels quick but take a look at
last girl from kappa blanca
and for those of you who um might need
to take a break and come back
be sure to join us for the uh next two
hours because we're gonna be doing game
analysis
and make sure to um
select the game or two and send it on
twitch in about an hour
maybe a little less and then we will be
doing
that there so yeah start thinking of
which game you want to show me
alright so um i kind of like this game
because i
um i played roy lopez here and there
and um kind of not
exactly my specialty i would say but i
actually have never ever played true
lopez
exchange variation which is so weird i
i've always wanted to like try different
lines just for the fun of it
but in this specific situation
i i've never tried that
all right it is 5 a.m in india
boy my sleep schedule is so so
messy uh let me tell you because i have
this
i study better at nights because during
the day so much
noise in this building so i started to
um shift my sleeping schedule and i was
up
until 6am last night which is not a very
healthy thing i don't recommend that to
anybody don't do it
but yeah uh this is not a website this
is my personal software
chess base um chess base i believe is
someone's professional
software for organizing your databases
keep keep tracking of them
loading strong engines but um beginner
intermediates you don't really need
transpace honestly but anyways they are
pretty great
all right um when it comes
to uh exchange relopez
it's quite interesting because there is
always a stigma
that you don't want to play something
like
um d4 because then it just goes to the
end game and
it's been like somehow it's believed
that you don't want to go to the end
game
but that's not necessarily true there is
it's it's very stigmatized and in recent
years
keep in mind this game was over a
hundred years ago
so in recent years it has been different
um and so
yeah d4 take take
take uh if black didn't want to take
bishop g4 is a recommended line as well
and again but the problem is that it's
not about who takes what
it's about if white wants to exchange
queens why we'll get to exchange queens
and
um the pawn structure so the whole the
whole
thing about roy lopez exchanged through
lopez is the pawn structure because
white wants to enjoy this extra
supposedly extra pawn and the majority
on this in the center and so yeah
that's what it is anywho
um after bishop g4 something like knight
c3 is possible the coins would get
exchanged
eventually and this is another
like there's so so many deep lines in
this
but i want to keep us to the main line
and if we have a little time i would
really like to come back and look at
this
uh very interesting endgame of it too
it's another game that lasker played in
a world championship match
in paris 1909 but
we are not really i mean i still really
want to watch it
but i would prefer to keep my focus
on this game and give us some time to
actually dive deep in the
end it's so weird to call this end game
because there's still so
many pieces on the board so when i say
ends game i'm always going to probably
give you a little
eyebrow twitch alright so
um c5 that's another line but
what about bishop d6 what do we think
about this move
so one thing to uh one thing that i
would absolutely love it if you guys
were able to communicate
and engaged in this is that well
what is white's plan and we kind of have
a
clear idea of what's the why what white
wants to
get into what wants to be able to use
this extra pot right
but it doesn't mean that black is
totally lost on
seven so how can black use that
how can black play with that
any suggestions black just played bishop
d6
[Music]
so
what do you think should happen
this is so quiet are you guys good you
need coffee because i got my tea here
that's a pretty good tape
soon in a few days i think in three days
we
have um it's the persian new year now so
i'm a little excited on that too
just need to survive this week
i like the idea of f45
i very much like knight c39 c3 is just a
move you should do
when you play well the ninth belongs on
c3 your knight on d2 or e3 wouldn't
really do any good
so let's keep this light on c3 and then
see where it goes
so after knight c3
what do you think black should do
because there there are a few good moves
um and one of the things that black
should definitely think of is where do
you want to place this king well not
right now but where do you want to go
short side long side
all right so i see a lot of ideas still
but in between
and i see a cute bear in the chat too so
i like bears bears are cute
all right so i see a lot of long i like
that
uh milan castle has been seen to be
played
much more recently i remember um i was
preparing to
play against i was training to play
the real opposite the exchange ratio as
black
and i remember that we worked so much on
the long castle ideas and they were
quite interesting there were some other
ideas too with like
short castle you put the rook on the
eight and then you put
um the other rook on let the other rook
stay on a8 and try to push the pawns but
it's um it's either side is fine
honestly
but back in 100 years ago
long castle was not as
um ideal
or promoted maybe maybe they just didn't
really
get to talk about it anyways um f6 is
another idea that's
very common too this would be
the game that's funnily enough happened
in the same
a year and same tournament between all
hand and lasker if capoblanca here
played f6 a lot of world champions in
this
uh in this um in our test on psychology
today it's
kind of getting weird on my tongue all
right so
um bishop e3 is another well way to do
it
and uh if white wanted to do long castle
this is this is a pretty cool way to do
it because this pawn on it
my problem with pawn on f6 is that when
you start to push like
f4 or e5 then it could be a little
complicated because
then your e-pawn could be lonely and
that's not necessarily
what's not everybody's dream to have
isolated pawns
so that's one thing if you wanted to
give this up 6 a try but 97 makes
pretty good sense too if you think about
it logically
um yeah thank you thank you honest
um if you think about it logically this
knight belongs on e7 because on f6
is just going to be under this pawns um
thumb i guess
and so we need this line to stay on e7
and
whites would most likely try to push the
kingside pawns right
so if i tried to push the kingside pawns
then we need to try and stop it we can't
just sit there and let it happen right
so let's say flight goes to e7
um that's what actually kava blanca did
in the game but
let's say we still get this castle
castle and then
f4 now what should black do because i'm
not just going to sit there and let you
play e5
and i'm not just gonna i don't want to
just start under the center and i don't
want to just
give you um
like a shoot pass palm so
any suggestions
it is restricted by the pawn but the
point is that white
wants to push this pawn so if the knight
was on f6
then e5 would be much easier for white
so we have to
we keep this knight on e7 so we can
fight it with f6 thank you yes
and um danny does castle instead of
knight c3 prevent knight f6
or does black wants to yeah black does
want to play knight
e7 anyways oops
i apologize for that let me also get my
microphone closer i forgot to do that
um you probably didn't really hear me
explode
all right um
please somebody let me know if
everything is fine in the chat
too i mean um microphone wise
i'm good i have a lot of allergies and
they are not helpful
so um after f4 capablanca
is um this move seems weak
with f4 but um it's kind of funny
because he said it after the game
and capablanca lost this game newswatch
and so it might have been like sore
loser talk
so that's another one too um it's kind
of fun kind of funny to see that
even world champions do that all right
so
f4 and um
capoblanca actually went for rookie
eight first
i this almost makes me a little
um i'm not really sure because
my my problem with jerky 8 is that if
you want to play f6
just do it already and if we played this
f6 then e5 is stopped but
at the same time my rook here is kind of
helping
not to clap this e5 but i can also see
how
rookie 8 would be interesting what if
rookie 8
this move e5 was played though
probably bishop c5 bishop e3
it's still a very very interesting game
and
maybe now i could even try to do 95.
it's a
big big maybe because um this
is still not really
the dream position but it would be it
would look pretty good at least this
almost fixed my pawn structure
so he eight might be an interesting
choice to try and trigger this e5
because then you would get bishop c5 and
oh
careful if knight f5 knight can just
take on f5
if here knight f5 was playing ah no not
bad go back
bad punk if knight f5 was played then
knight would just take on f5
and
you know you would kind of lose a piece
so let's try to
keep that together be very careful with
these little
um sneaky night moves so let's say white
plays knight to b3 now what should black
do now i really want to play this e5
what do you think black should do
f5 well if you play f5 then e5
still happens so yeah i like f6
now what should happen oh yes
hello i'm annie sorry i kind of missed
that part
yeah i like f6 no more e5s but
now even though there are no more e5s
what do you think white can do white has
a very strong move right now
nope we this is not a regular
we should um we should definitely always
develop
but at the same time opponents want to
develop bishop upon from the level of
knight
so can we somehow take those away from
opponents
exactly thank you fragrance have fun
f5 it is now this f5 is blocking the
bishop is blocking the knight so
black should start thinking about a way
to activate his pieces
because if you don't activate your
pieces then you're not really losing
them so
and the interesting part is that tarash
called this move
exceptionally surprising and fine which
sounds like a compliment but it's also a
little
fine i mean fine come on f5 is not fine
f5 is cool
uh and i didn't really think it should
have worked but
yeah i think this f5 was pretty awesome
so i'm gonna go with cool and awesome
exceptionally surprising cool and
awesome and excite uh instead of
taj calling it exceptionally surprising
and fine
yeah um thank you thank you almost for
the for the details thank you
that's extremely helpful
um yeah
so um it's gonna be a complex battle
because
uh white is kind of putting pressure on
black right and white has this like
extra cute pawn
and um john
don't worry there is no real wrong
answers as long as you
get something out of the position pc
has found a new sleeping spot on top of
the fridge
inside of a cabinet and he is
loving it he does not come out of there
like i'm not sure if that's all
okay or not but he's just always there
unless
i open the door and he wants to run
outside but today is a little rainy
and or when i go to actually sleep in my
own bed he follows me and he snaps with
me it's so true
all right back to the big chest guys of
vlaska capoblanca
unfortunately peaches can only out
cute them i don't think you can outplay
them
so f5 now
after f5 um this move
b6 now what do you think about that
gotta get this bishop out so probably
have to do this b6 and c5 at some point
but then you get your bishop out then
what about your knights the knights
would be actually pretty interesting if
it was on e5
but then if your knight is on e5 your
bishop is blocked
so you see how it's a constant back and
forth
if you open this then you're going to
block that if you block that then you're
going to open this
so yeah um
after b6 bishop f4 now i kind of want to
know
do you guys think that the bishop
exchange should happen so should black
take it over here
or should black just let it be and just
like play bishop b7 and develop
keep in mind if white takes my bishop
i'll just take it back with the pawn and
my planet structure is kind of fixed
kind of big emphasis on kind of
never play f6 that is
hey buddy usually that's true but
there are instances that is not exactly
relevant i mean that doesn't exactly go
that way especially when
um when your opponent is about to take
the whole center then
f6 is kind of needed or
when you know opponent is trying to
play something like e5 or
or when there is no white color bishop
to attack my king and enjoy this um
diagonal then yes f6 is doable
but most circumstances f6 is not the way
to go
so now um it's kind of interesting
because
i also thought that taking is not
the best move but black should have
sorry black should have taken this
take take and um
let's see bye this is the way black
should have played
and then continued it so it's getting a
bishop free and then getting trying to
exchange some pieces and it's still not
as ideal the position as you would want
it to be but
your bishop is somewhat open your knight
is gonna come to e5 or d4
and it's it's still strong position
there's still a lot to be
um played so that's why it's
i'm not exactly uh let me try to
find the right way to say papa blanca
made a mistake without saying come blank
i made a mistake
yeah so carlonka made a mistake which is
kind of funny because i am a huge huge
fan of capoblanca
and to me he doesn't make mistakes and
but unfortunately in this game he did
and he played
bishop b7 he didn't want to exchange the
bishops
i assume because he was really conscious
focused concentrate no wait
i can't say it my english is not working
uh because this um
in this opening well in this
oh he was very focused on his pawn
structure
and so i assume that black didn't really
care as much about
um peace activity as he should have and
he just kind of focused on okay
great if he takes it i'll take back and
i'll just have my peace activity
um pawn structure fixed and somewhat of
peace activity but compare this position
with this position box
feels more free it feels like it's
breathing
so yeah
anyway after knight d4
let's i'm gonna ask you what do you
think black should do
because black is the one who is a little
bit in the
pickle right like black is trying to
figure out how to
get his pieces working but it's not
exactly working the way he wants it to
it fixes the pawn structure the piece
activity
is not working so what do you think
d5 might be too early
keep in mind this line is about to jump
into some really weird squares
just to give you another idea of why
bishop b7 was not exactly ideal and
bishop plays f4 should have been played
um kasparov also called bishop b7 a
fundamental mistake
which um and the capablanca later kind
of confessed that
he played it and he kind of overlooked
opponents reply
and yeah so even big guys like couple
blanca
have made horribly weird mistakes not
blundering
well i'm sure they've done that too but
not blundering but
positional um nuts like not
understanding the position which is so
out of character and we don't expect
that not from cuppa blanco not from
world champions so
it shows how people under pressure break
so um let's go after knight d4
what do you think black is gonna do now
great fragrance actually that's kind of
cool yeah that is a psychology of it
thank you it's kind of why i call this
class just on psychology
all right bishop c8 is the way to go
after bishop c8
um now
white is kind of um you know
what has some issues white can't really
enjoy this
knight going to e6 and then would get c5
then now you gotta move this knight back
okay e6 maybe just think think and you
gotta move this knight back
and then this one is still a little weak
so probably a rook d8
i'm gonna knight c6 but you see we're
pushing back you should push back
bishop cs would be the way to push back
um
kappa blanca by drook v8 96 37
48 and here papa blanca made
not very efficient move so you see why
this game is one of my favorite ones
even though
i totally totally love papa blanca he
messed up
in this game so yeah
kind of fun to see that
now after rook d1 what do you think
black
should play and i know i keep asking you
what should black play because if black
played the best moves then this position
this game wouldn't be
as interesting for us
thank you thank you and manny yeah i
tried to keep the theme colors
all kind of a happy summery color
warm
i see d5 i see g3
g6
d5 does not work right now and the rook
on d7 is too wonderful
the pieces are not ready you won't be
able to do it look
d8 because of that light on e6 so
you can't you can't do that you need to
figure out a way to kick this knight
can we ever kick knights or get king in
the game
that's kind of the idea we're hoping to
kick knight uh
c5 might be the way it looks a little
uh not exactly happy because there is
this knight d5 and if you take
take then you try to push on the other
side and that knight on e6
is just too painful
and then like whites will start pushing
over here and then there and it's not
exactly what we want
so yeah
c5 might have been worth a try but
knight d5 kind of makes it quite
hard to go for um
in the game black played knight c8 and
after knight c8 white continued to jerk
f2
what do you think of rook f2
i know right what is this knight c8 i'm
assuming that
black wants to continue with like b5 as
he did in the game
and trying to maybe activate this knight
but it's just too
painful like this pawn is here the
knight is defending it the bishop is
blocked behind there is just so
ugly um
yeah so black is still trying
to create something i don't
exactly know why i mean i know the why
but what
and here capablanca did the ultimate
move he played bishop a8 and
i i understand it he probably wants to
swing the rook to the other side and
probably wants to try and
create something on the queen side but
if you have to play bishop a8 is the
equivalent of a relationship
dying and then people just kind of
staring at each other and being oh
honey i love you please don't go but the
relationship is dead so bishop eight
doesn't exactly work so
instead of doing that that's knight on
e6 that very strong poisonous light
take it that's what you should have done
it's kind of radical and it's not
exactly um ideal
to lose that but that's what
that's what you should have tried
and yeah it's a sad metaphor
but it's real life thank you i'm glad
some people like my metaphor
there we go peachy's been going through
a breakup with one of his stray cats i'm
kidding all the stray cats come back for
peachy
food all right um
so that's that's most likely what black
should have tried to
gain some peace activity and
um that's kind of it would be it would
be interesting yeah
honestly i am kind of singing in my head
it's my happy place so
yeah um anyways
after a tree bishop a8
oh i can give you another example which
of the eight is like
no that's again metaphorical could be
something sad therefore
no it's it's okay bishop you get that
you're just looking at it you wanna go
also i've been trying to watch some
episodes on
um the tv show bones and it's just too
early
anywho um
i'm glad you feel that way captain um
i do like music but i um it's a it's a
little
i don't know how to explain it club
policy let's go with that
no music for now might change later but
for now we're still sticking with no
music
all you're gonna hear is the sound of my
fridge and maybe laptop overheating
no ice cream falling on the ground is
that sad but this is like this is cruel
i want something because i'm a cruel
metaphor
yeah oh
stop okay so i'm glad you guys liked my
dying relationship metaphor yeah so we
can go with that bishop
yank is a dying relationship and
yeah so bishop aids king of two
see white's doing fine bringing the king
up
using some space and black is just
shifting some pieces around oh
am i playing when i watch oh wait i
don't think you're talking to me
fragrance
yeah um so g4 rook case rookie 7 g4 you
see black has some ideas of pushing
pawns
but
not necessarily going to happen just yet
because white is also bringing some
force on the king's side and
you see my king is here so i have to
care even a little bit to try and stop
this
thank you thank you i'm glad everybody
likes my analogy
uh alright so after age six
what
waiting for apocalypse nah it's not that
it's like i think kava blanco knew his
position was kind of sucky
but he was still trying but his best
tribe would have been to
you know take on e6 and give it up that
would be breaking up on time for example
but then you when you played rook a7
it's like you know
the relationship is sad and dying and
there's so many problems but you still
want to keep going
or who knows why and yeah so that's kind
of why it's not exactly apocalypse it's
more like
still trying and still miserably trying
anyways uh
after reggae seven and h6
then see white is still being super
active bringing the rook
finally black tries to open that slide
up a little bit
but it is not enough now here
the move that black did i this move that
papa blanca did
just this move let me let me try to find
a
way to explain it ah exactly this is
when you've broken up with someone and
then the next day you call them oh hey
honey just kidding
i'm coming back so this move is like
that do you want to guess what this move
is
crocodile whoa no no no look i don't
want no murder on my channel
um so
what move do you think is in this
position is the equivalent of
calling the person you broke up with and
being like ha
just kidding exactly rick goes back
rookie seven exactly
that's the way to do it rookie seven is
exactly yeah oops made a mistake i
didn't mean to do that
rookie 7 is that so avoid those don't do
those mistakes in real life or in chess
preferably
yep no we're going there uh rook a3
you're already committed you already
played this rook a7 just
bring it to a32 and then
here um well rookie 3 should have been
played but
kava blanca made another mistake and he
didn't do it
and if pro k3 was played this would be a
nice way for white to continue you get
rid of that
one active piece that black has the
knights is still
here defending this set upon the bishop
is here defending this guy
so yeah
and after wreck e7 now what
okay one interesting i actually didn't
think about that
the spawn of the moment
i'm i'm very focused on the king slide
so we're trying to figure out exactly
how to try and
push this g5
you guys are gonna love this let me give
you another
metaphor this might be hard because
white is having a great time
um now i can't give any
crappy relationship metaphors with this
hmm
let's see
oh this might be hard to pull off
yep i got nothing
so um i can give you
i can give you a little hint though
every single piece
in white's position is doing something
this knight is stopping c5 this knight
is just
paralyzing black this rook is stopping
this light from moving
um this rook on d1
could move somewhere but it's not
exactly necessary
so the idea yeah exactly the idea
is to try and bring this pawn to g5 but
we need a little bit more
um support thank you thank you your slop
king gotta go to f4 boom
now if black tries to play something
like g5
you just bring it back and then later on
slowly slowly rook h1
enjoy this one add a file
and boom yep
yeah i'm very stressed over my
horrible week like i made a list and let
me just
show you this is a list of the things
that i have to write
over weekend just two days and it was
too much typing and i still have to
watch another some little things for my
tomorrow exam
and i am not ready for that i really
really hope
i survived this exam
it's painful anywho not going to sit
here and
talk about exam as long as there are
awesome
crappy relationship metaphors to give so
what about g6 should we take that
i could always use an assistant that is
true
i agree we shouldn't take that we don't
want to give up our knights right there
you go
that should give you some answers so
how about rook g3
simple simple i just want to play g5 i
want to chill
wow sharma you have a test in three
hours and you are watching me
you are amazing i
probably will have to stay up all night
well i am not ready for this test
anywho after g6 for
g3 what if g5 let me also tell you what
if take
if take we would simply take back and
then go for g5
amazing right if hey i mean if tank just
take
take and that pawn will
be very painful see that's the
equivalent of
breaking up with someone and then
getting they get engaged like the next
day to someone else
i think this position is like that for
black there we go that's as dark as it
could get
ah awesome
but uh black tried to make it a little
um long lasting i guess
by playing g5
and now once
we shouldn't should we take that because
i don't really want to take that
little pawns are irritating yep i don't
really want to take that because if i
take that
then just takes back and then i gotta
move my king
and that's i mean i have to move my king
anyways but
i really really don't want to take that
just because if i take it
if you take it with the with the other
pawn there's a king coming to f6
but if you even take it with
you even take it with this guy
and there's still again i white still
has much better
game on the h file but black
can still fight quite a lot on this and
i don't really want to give you that
satisfaction
so i'm gonna go with king f3 i'm not
gonna take it just yet
i'm gonna take that though and then
i'm gonna go there see we could have
taken over here
but there are issues this knights could
get very very active and then this
knight could jump to e5
and let's say you move your rook
wherever
and then not just knight to e5 even
rick8
now the string is active this knight is
active this bishop is
still quite miserable to be honest but
it's getting there it's trying
so i don't want to do that i don't want
to
give you that satisfaction so i'm going
to go with rook to h3
and now what
thank you thank you i'm glad you guys
are enjoying yes
yeah see breakups help all you got to do
is just put them in the
chest amount wait no that's not i said
that reversed
uh iman i am not a med student yet i am
studying for the exam and cats to get
into the medical schools
wait why would i take a draw why is
better anyways after
rick h3 um if might see four you could
just give this check and then you could
just bring the strip to the other side
which is so
so so cool because see you can't really
take it over here
because then you would lose this bad boy
you gotta move back
and bam i just want a piece
so bishop b7
and this would also be a quite pleasant
way for white
to continue a lot of different
ideas so black play drug d7 now this
here is something that
i didn't think of and i was quite
ashamed that i didn't think of
so watch the move what do you think
white should do
thank you very much
so all the ideas that you guys are
giving is quite valid
but something like my
king going to g3 blew my mind and i
believe the idea is that
if you play knight c4 you want to go
knight d5 i don't want to be
in the crossfire of the check so that's
why we would
try to go king to g3
and after that when kappa blanca
played king e8 now he doubled her up
and if something like knights before
boomer h8
and if bishop to b7 then just
this cool e5 e5 is a move that i don't
think it's too hard to find because we
we have to include the last piece in the
game and the best to go
is on e4 and if take just knight e4 i
won't jump into f6
ah if you did that then this is another
oh knight takes g5 oh my god this is so
pretty
where is my checkmates it should be
right here right just
check another check
maybe the other night can i just there
we go
there is my checkpoint
what's wrong with drug h7 um where
oh i'm so sorry i do not hear myself
when i'm
streaming so if you guys could give me a
little
insight on what type should it bring to
my front closer should i
scream i don't want to scream i'm not a
screamer
yes so that's why d takes e5
is like one last try still knight goes
to e4 i still want to take on f6
i still want to jump to c5 there we go
jump to c5
this would also work actually take take
and just then go into c5
oh uh the low hum would be my laptop
overheating i apologize for that
let me try to move some stuff around
maybe gets a little better
all right um also this knight going to
c5
is another cool way to win
and if tries to defend that i could just
even take that guy and just attack that
guy
and just bring the rig from the other
side this reminds me of the game i had
with jennifer you
i was moving my rooks around a lot too
anyways check and just knight c5
see rook d7 is coming up for checkmate
ideas
i guess knight b7 will do the job 196.
there are three ways to check mates
right now
so kind of hurtful anyways i hope you
guys enjoyed this game this was a very
beautiful game played by
oscar and capoblanca capablanca kind of
um
helped lasker a lot so
i'm glad that you guys have been with me
for the past hour so
we are going to switch to twitch pretty
soon so
um please go ahead and try to find the
best games you want
to send me and um well
just send them to me on twitch
preferably make sure that they are
from leeches uh it's easier to
work with leeches because i'm going to
be analyzing games unleash us
and we're gonna stream only just so do
that please
um we're gonna do that for two hours so
yep basically switch to twitch and yes
uh please give please be there in about
10 minutes or so
i'm gonna have to um wash up get more
tea and
change um the key but
i'll see you guys there in about 10
minutes so
please be ready follow our twitch
channel make sure to
um be ready to start sending the games
oh i see someone already sent the game
wow yeah so follow the twitch channel
um send your games what about my exam
i'll go study after this next two hours
with you
alright uh this was amazing i feel much
better
and um i'll see you guys in 10 minutes